if you watch live pd
there's a sheriff on that show called
sheriff lamb okay
sheriff lamb is uh it was one of the
most popular
shows uh for police and the the show was
canceled i believe it was the show
canceled
eventually the show was canceled right i
want to call sheriff lamb to see what he
thinks about what's going on right now
in uh uh in what do you call it in
france with this new
law that they're proposing to see what
he has to say okay let me know if you
guys are ready
you guys ready we're good with the call
okay hello it's mark
mark how are you this is patrick the
david with adam and tom ellsworth
how you doing patrick i'm doing tom i'm
doing great man i appreciate you taking
some time so
i wanted to get your feedback on this i
don't know if you heard about what
happened in france and what announcement
they're making i'll read it to you
then you tell us your thoughts on this
uh uh and if this
is possible and if it's good for the
people if it's not good for the people
and can this be something that can have
momentum that can lead into u.s so
here's what france is talking about
uproar in france over proposed
limits on filming police french
president emmanuel macron
government is pushing a new security
bill that makes it illegal to publish
images of police officers with intent to
cause them harm
amid other measures critics fear the new
law
could hurt press freedoms and make it
more difficult for all citizens to
report on
police brutality french activists fear
that a proposed new security law will
deprive them
of a potent weapon against abuse
cell phone videos of police activity
threatening their effort to document
possible cases of police
brutality especially in impoverished
immigrant neighborhoods what are your
thoughts about
this potential new uh bill
that macron is trying to push in france
you know at first i
i thought it's a little bit of a
violation of this for of the first
amendment but
then i started reading into it a little
bit further and and you know what
we don't get the protection that we need
it is not fair
a lot of times the media uses the first
amendment to go above and beyond what i
think it was
designed for nobody's impeding their
ability to go out and report
all we're saying is i i see what the
french are doing what they're saying is
saying
you can't put somebody else's life at
risk because you didn't like the actions
and how many times have we seen videos
where they don't show you the full
context of your video either
and i think it's unfair to those
officers to be blasted out there
and we've seen our media look at what
they've done they'll put your
address out there on social media
they'll put your face out there
and uh that puts our lives in our
families at risk
either so i don't think the first
amendment was designed i don't think the
founding fathers had the intentions of
of putting the very same people who
protect you every night
at risk because you decided the media
decided they didn't like how you did
your job
now does that say that we shouldn't i'm
not saying you need to hide the actions
of bad officers absolutely
not this stems from a a a
this stems because of a violation of the
constitution
the french don't have but the this comes
this is getting a lot of attention
because of that uh where they beat that
guy up in the hallway and the recording
student
do you know what they beat him up over
no
he wasn't wearing a mask they beat him
up because he wasn't wearing a mask and
he probably resisted against it so
we're in this weird spot in this world
where you know we
we want to violate certain rights of the
constitution of people's freedoms but
then the media wants to retain their
full rights
and even expound on it to where i think
the founding fathers didn't have the
intention of them being
so you're actually thinking this is not
a bad idea on what they're trying to do
in france
well i see what they're trying to do i
don't know that you can do it here and
i'm i'm a very staunch
supporter of the constitution i just
think that it is inappropriate
it's no different than if i were to put
out the media's addresses on my website
have you ever heard the saying the pen
is mightier than the sword i will assure
you
that the media causes more violence in
this country with what they write and
what they report
than what the police do so we can
totally agree with you on that
completely
100 agreement these guys want to
continue to incite people and anger
people
why else would you need to know and want
to report somebody's address
that's what they're arguing over they
don't like the fact that they can't put
these guys on blast
for their actions and and jeopardize
them why would you want to do that in
the first place that's not the job of
the media
and it's not appropriate that the media
do that anyway
sheriff lamb this is adam here i have a
question for you um
sure obviously 2020 has been a insane
year
you've been right i mean you've been uh
police officer sheriff for how many
years now
total uh four now going into my second
floor
okay so i just from a macro perspective
what have you seen specifically
change uh
rules-wise but more more importantly
perception like do people come up to you
with the same amount of respect do you
get a lot of pushback still
obviously everything since george floyd
blm
you know defund the police just more of
a macro question like what are you
seeing on the ground or
do people still respect you are people
you know
proverbially spinning your face [ __ ] you
pig like what are you seeing out there
um 20 20 that's a great question
that actually depends on where you live
you know here in my county we have
people that are very pro police and what
this
has done is this has made people
appreciate their law enforcement even
more
so i think there's a lot of places in
this country where they've always
appreciated law enforcement and now
they've said hey we appreciate you guys
even more for what you're doing
there are other cities where they've
where the local government has allowed
the
this behavior to continue and this
anti-police behavior to continue and so
that's emboldened a lot of the people
who don't like police to spit in your
face and to say these things
and actually in many cases i think
they're violating the law
they're either disorderly conduct or
they're i don't think anybody should
ever be within a flood or two of a law
enforcement agent
you know set up some barricades move
them back they're right they have they
have their right to protest under the
first amendment
they don't have the right to stick your
phone in a cop space i don't think
that's appropriate
um i think that that starts getting into
the oh so so you said you don't think
they have the right to put a phone
camera in a
cop's face well i think what it gets
into is officer safety you know we have
a right we have a job to protect the
public and we also have a job to protect
ourselves
and how do i protect the public when
somebody's got a phone in my face and i
can't see what's going on
i think that what these cities need to
do is and we've done it here there's
been a lot of
agencies in our state that have they've
set up barricades and they said you guys
are free to
to protest right here in this area you
know we're not get we're not
impeding on that right but don't cross
over this barricade because
this is a zone that we're trying to
protect you know this is the safe
we're trying to maintain officer safety
and public safety here
so i think that what we've what the
media has shown and what has been
allowed
i think is we're pushing the envelope
and it's making our job even harder in
law enforcement
sheriff this is tom ellsworth the biz
doc i got a question for you
hey how are you i appreciate your your
thoughtfulness here
so can you comment a little bit because
i i think i'm i'm hearing it
between the lines there it's like you
take a look at portland
so they created this dmz or was it
seattle who had the uh the free zone
downtown
yeah that was chess yeah i think is in
north korea
yeah well but you you get the point
right yeah because you're
creating a free zone and so there were
the police actually
got stuck on the perimeter of that and
couldn't go
inside and there were people that really
needed help and people are on the inside
that established it suddenly a couple of
them needed help
so it is kind of a two-faced answer by
the protest
public right yeah i mean
what they did was completely different
they set up a whole free zone where
people could go in
and they violated people's what about
all those businesses who had their
businesses destroyed that was your job
as a law enforcement officer
to protect those to maintain that you
know keep to maintain the peace
here in the arizona the constitution
says my job as a sheriff is to
suppress any affrays insurrections riots
or any lawlessness that comes into the
county
what they did was tried to be cute and
set up this and i'm not saying it was
the portland or the seattle police
their government thought it would be
best to set up a zone where people could
just run a buck
and not keep them in check i look i was
listening to you guys show earlier
kind of you know what what we've done is
we've started we've started allowing
like like uh patrick was talking about
iran
we're just saying oh hey guys if we'll
give you this spot if you don't
if you just don't be violent or the
other thing
and we will you can't do that that's
children will react
until completely unruly if you do that
the best example you gave was hey i'll
give you a hundred dollars if you guys
just play your
xbox quietly no you take the xbox away
that's how you're going to get them to
uh to behave and
look there's a fine line people are
going to not like what i'm saying and
i'm very constitutional minded but
we have adultered the first amendment
there have been groups that have
they have taken the first amendment and
completely adultered the first amendment
with either their what they say their
their freedom of speech
or also even more in particular their
right to protest
to address greed to redress grievances
with the government
you don't do that at 11 o'clock at night
all the government buildings are shut
down
so i mean look there's a we've we've
adultered the first amendment we've got
to get it in check get it back
i'm not saying to violate people's
rights but we can't let the first
amendment go to where it wasn't supposed
to be
mark what do you think is going to
happen under a bite administration with
uh
police i mean you're seeing what uh
create a momentum with defunding the
police
then you're seeing biden originally
people were worried sanders was going to
be on the
you know his cabinet people were worried
aoc was going to have a position
elizabeth warren was going to have a
position none of that happened
but they were able to get a lot of those
guys to help them get elected
do you think he's going to be aggressive
like against cops or do you think he's
going to be
fairly reasonable with
your world with police officers cops
sheriffs
all the folks out there that do what you
do well i think it's first and foremost
important to understand that he is not
the president-elect he has not been
dedicated
he has not been determined by the
electoral college to be the
president-elect
the media has claimed of him to be the
president-elect so first and foremost
i think it's important to distinguish
that he is a guy pretending to be the
president-elect right now
um it is likely that he will be the
president-elect i'm not sandy walt
but as until december 14th he's not
um it will be terrible under biden i
think this year
showed during all the riots and the
looting and all these different things
they had an opportunity to come out and
stand against that and and to support
the law enforcement agencies across this
country
and they failed to do so not only did
they fail to do so
their silence or in many cases some of
the rhetoric that they put out there
was inflammatory towards law enforcement
so
i i don't you in law enforcement we can
only go off of what we see
and what i saw was a lack of support for
law enforcement
and what concerns me more than joe biden
because i just frankly don't think that
if joe biden should he be elected as
president
i don't think that he stays in office
very long i'm more concerned about the
people that he keeps running up there as
pa
potential candidates for these uh these
positions i think that's alarming to me
a lot of them are very very radical
very uh progressive and i don't think
that is good for police officers
and we're starting to see already the
failures of some of these policies
across this country but you have
minnesota
a lot of different places so i think a
biden administration is terrible for law
enforcement
and uh we'll have a lot of work to do
and
unfortunately i think in a lot of places
you're going to see a lot more handcuffs
put on than what they've been on
interesting who concerns you the most
from the people he's proposed
um i don't really think that the
policies that his
potential chief of staff is uh putting
out there are very good i think
you know talks of elizabeth warren um
some of these other folks i kamala
harris concerns me
i i think that kamala harris has proven
over time
based on what i see as somebody who will
say and do anything for votes power or
money
and anytime you're talking that that is
a that is a
ticking time bomb having somebody in
public office if that's what they're
willing to put you know
they'll do anything for those three
things and anybody should be concerned
over that
well brother appreciate you for coming
on and spending a few minutes with us
and giving us insight on your world for
uh
uh us who hear all these different
stories on both sides of the aisle on
politics when you watch cnn fox msnbc
uh it's much easier for me to just call
someone like you to say hey tell us
what's really going on the street so
again
thank you for your time appreciate you
buddy and hopefully we'll have you back
on here soon and you'll be willing to
come back on as a guest again
all right thanks guys i appreciate it
take care bye bye bye
so you know i don't know i don't know
what's going to happen you know you see
you see these uh
going back to the whole thing with the
camera remember how yesterday we were
talking about i said i don't know if i'm
fully against it
do you remember when we were talking
about the whole friend's camera thing
yesterday i'm like i'm not if i'm fully
against it
there's a part of it that like the other
day i got pulled over right yesterday i
got a
reckless driving ticket whatever i asked
uh sheriff lamb about that yeah well
you know my my license was suspended
multiple times so it's not the breaking
news
pack got pulled over again so i got so i
got a ticket yesterday and this guy
pulls me over right and i said okay i'll
pull over the car i've done this i
probably have more tickets than
everybody in this room combined i don't
think anybody
if we combine how many tickets you got
total in your lifetime
total four i have 75 tickets
80 tickets i'm not kidding and that's
the step by the way bro for for the
first 12 months we were here i got three
tickets
a week that my staff had to pay for
every week okay how do you still have a
license
i don't have a life i lost my license a
couple of times but but let me let me go
but
let me make this point to you so cop
pulls me over and by the way i've been
pulled over all over the world
so it's all over i've been pulled over
no i got pulled over by a cop yesterday
okay and he pulls me over i'm like look
i screwed up i said what do we need to
do he says oh hi
well thank you for uh pulling over the
car and
and uh uh you know if you don't mind
taking out your driver's license
and i don't want to grab it from you
because i want to make sure you're
you're
healthy you feel comfortable with it
would you mind turning your idea over
i'm like wait a minute what the
hell was this all about so i turn my
driver's license over he uh gets the
whatever code is on the screen
okay he says yeah okay you know we're
doing this for your safety and i'm like
great guys got a mask on a cop's got a
mask on he's talking to me
and i said so uh anything you need from
me says oh no i just want to let you
know look i know
you know it's i'm not trying to bother
you i just want you to know that one
thing you have on the back i mean if you
don't mind you know
i'm not going to give you a ticket for
it then like i mean i got a cavity he
was so sweet just listen to the guy the
least i've never heard a copy this week
it was out of control uncomfortably
saying he was being too nice he was
being so
nice and he was so uncomfortable big guy
probably 18-inch arms massive guy this
guy was
he was talking to me like that and i
walked away saying to myself
this is the nicest cop that's ever
pulled me over out of all the 75 tickets
i got i've never had a nicer cup
is that because of his personality or is
that because cops are told
be a little nicer to people nowadays try
to be a little bit more amicable
to people nowadays be careful because
they may be recording be careful because
maybe cop do i want cops to be scared do
you want scared cops
i don't know if i want scared cops do
you want cops to be
so scared of what they need to do that
they're thinking about being politically
correct rather than protecting you
i don't know if i'm going to war and
telling my soldiers hey guys
make sure when we're going out there you
don't talk about
what they wear you don't talk about
their clothes because we don't want to
piss them off
and so let's be respectful before we
kill them what the hell are you talking
about
so now that's in the war i'm not talking
about cops are doing the same thing
but i kind of also want to empower cops
i don't want to take the power away from
cops
i want cops to have power i don't want
cops to not have any kind of power
i'm not telling you for people not to
have power of course i want the people
to have power
but i think there's a part of it here
where
it's a slippery slope but also at the
same time i understand why
cops would not be happy with somebody
saying okay say it
say can you imagine if somebody goes
like this to you right now what's your
initial reaction go ahead it's annoying
as [ __ ]
yeah you just got pissed off so you're a
cop go ahead go ahead you're live
hey i just want to let you know he did
this sexual harassment
didn't i don't know i mean i'd be like
you know what i'd go to my i'd go to my
boss on monday i'd say
boss i'm just not made for to be a cop
i'm good i don't like cameras on my face
24 7. i'm good
i resign just some quick feedback
i hear you on both sides i hear the
sheriff i hear what you're saying
you know the cop that pulled you over
i don't see anything wrong with him not
being an [ __ ]
what do i mean by that let me let me
unpack most cops are not as i'm not
saying that
when cops pull you over yeah you're not
a freaking criminal because you were
speeding 10 miles over the speed limit
okay
there's no reason to be like all right
buddy put your hands on the wheel let me
see your [ __ ]
let's go and they just dude okay just
give me a [ __ ] ticket let's move on
with our life yeah you don't have to be
a total
[ __ ] about it that is a lot of cops
though like i've been pulled
over a handful of times i disagree i've
had very little listen to what he said
listen to what he said
listen to when he said we have to be
able to reason okay we have to be
it's comments like that that ruins
people's reputation imagine somebody who
lives in the worst part of town where
majority of the people are el salva
salvadorian and they live
in the capital of marasavatrucha go to
place in l.a i met a lot of salvadorian
they're all like this [ __ ]
you just so happen to live in the
capital of a place where ms-13 is at
i we just had an uh el salvadorian guy
in our company crossed a million dollars
this week
okay he's been with us for five years he
was a former economist in el salvador
third highest uh uh great in his class
the entire country ended up giving him a
scholarship to go to any country becomes
an economist comes to the states
now him and his wife rodolfo and cecil
vargas just crossed a million dollar
income he's salvador and i don't say
oh because i went to glendale and i was
in eagle rock all the time around ms-13
all salvadorians are like that
the guy said when we asked the question
you asked a question from him
how is it today being a cop in 2020 how
is it do people spit in your face and
what was his answer that's where you
live right
exactly so you can't say that about cops
everywhere just because
i wasn't not making a blanket statement
well you did what kind of no i
know okay we have to run the tapes go
back and listen two minutes ago
just because they pull you over they
don't have to be an [ __ ] no you said
most cops are [ __ ] i i'm not saying
most cops are asking okay i did not say
that rewind the tape and okay
gladly because those words i said
there's no reason that they have to be
an [ __ ] just most of them are not
[ __ ]
i'm not saying that they are but if you
get a ticket yeah like you're surprised
that he was sweet
i was actually like all right cool he
wasn't being at like hey man like
i don't want you you have to build up
you don't want to be like give me your
let me see your stuff
you want him to be me i don't want
listen i don't want
the coaches to my kids i don't
i don't think it's appropriate for a
police officer to be that sweet
okay i don't think it is i think there's
a there's a fine line between
authoritative and being mean
i don't say be authoritative i'm not
telling you be sweet
for me i think i think you have to be in
the middle for a position like that
that's what i'm saying right he's not in
the middle
i'm telling you he was scared okay i
thought he was just being nice i don't
know why i don't know if he was scared
he was
he said he was being sweet and you
almost got a cavity because he was nice
overly sweet and nice you're taking it
to he was sweet because he was scared he
was afraid
right that's a different story i thought
he was just being nice no i didn't even
know
being nice no no he was being a little
bit too scared because
what if somebody makes a complaint and
what if this i'm like no man you don't
want your job
it's like you always talk what i told
them that's what i told him i just want
you know man i appreciate what you do
he said i just want you to know you're
very important to me yeah
very important to me how did he respond
he was shell-shocked
really he's shell-shocked he's like
you're serious so you have no idea how
much you mean to me i appreciate your
job
because on anything on any given day
your wife and kids don't know if you're
going to go home tonight i sell
insurance i'm going home tonight unless
if i screw up on the freeway i'm
probably going to make it home tonight
they don't know if you're going to go
home tonight your mom your your daughter
your son
this may be the last time they saw you
this morning i got a lot of respect for
cops
and when you forget that part it's very
easy when the whole story about soldiers
were coming back from war back in the
days and people were spitting in their
face at airports disgusting you freaking
kidding me do you realize what they just
said they missed the birth of their kids
you're sitting here
spitting in the guy's face because he
gave you freedom and all they did is
follow the orders of a president that
told them to go to war it's not like
they made a decision to go to war
correct
they were they chose to go to war
because the president called the shot
what are you doing spitting in their
faces
i think i think we have to have respect
for military
i think we have to have respect for
officers but i also think we have to
have respect for
people i think the one thing that we
need to be spending more time talking
about is basic respect
it's just respect right you got to
respect we the people we the people's
got to respect cops
we the people got to respect military we
just have to respect one another
if we come from that standpoint and we
love we do our best to love one another
we got some stuff to do here 100 agree
with but we have to lead we can be
little soft he's afraid because i may
say something that's going to be like oh
my gosh let me be careful because of
political correctness i'm 100 agreement
with you you know statistically speaking
the most um dangerous thing officers do
you know what it is
statistics if you look at all the
incidents you know what it is pull
somebody over
the number of incidents that start with
a pullover is there
because a lot of times people are
speeding for a reason driving recklessly
for a reason
under the influence have committed a
crime things like that you know
and so you listen to police officers say
listen when you pull somebody over
here's what i have to do and i've heard
this they say i have to be cautious
i have to be clear and i got to be firm
and
when i'm walking up to the window of
that vehicle i'm cautious and i'm going
to be very clear with that driver then i
got to be firm now are there some cops
that go over the edge
sure but i think body cams dash cams
kind of neutralize that because what did
you say what tone of voices you have
it's being recorded because your duty
day is being recorded
and i think the people with camera
phones at the perimeter
you know i have no trouble with that i
have big trouble
when people jump into the middle of an
active police action
and they're putting the cameras in their
face you're you're inciting it you're
creating something that's not there and
by the way something the sheriff said
it's absolutely true
it's not about protests we have the
right to free assembly and we have the
right to
free speech but we also have disturbing
the peace and we have a lot of
parameters that go along that
peaceful protest peaceful marches you
know
that's where it's got to go and when you
have these people that create these mob
scenes yeah and they're jumped they're
creating incidents within what they call
as a protest
and they're giving everyone license you
know to
like attack what's what's the underlying
current there
is there is a attack on authority and
the police represent authority
and they're getting attacked in what's
going on in the protest right now
and i think we need to appreciate the
fact that are there some bad cops
sure there are however just take a look
at body cams dash cams
and recording what's going on and
appreciate the fact that statistically
speaking the most dangerous thing a
policeman does
is pull you is pull people over it's a
question mark you pull somebody over
it's a question
you got to respect you know it's kind of
it's kind of like when you work at a
company at them
and all of a sudden your employees
flip on you okay and it happens to
different leaders i have it happen to
our sales leaders all the time and it
happens to
department leaders all the time tom
tom's very aware of this as well he's
been in the world for a long time and
he's seen this happen
it's when the boss becomes afraid of
losing employees
when you get afraid of losing employees
to the point where you start making
decisions based on afraid afraid of
losing employees
you officially lost the ability to lead
your company
lead your department you can't be like
that now let's flip it
if you are losing employees because you
treat them like crap
you're getting what you deserve so you
have to understand that part as well
so it's not just the one side like when
a guy oh god you know
well maybe you got some things you got
to work on man some way you treat people
like you may want to
work a little bit more on that
relationship thing i'm not telling you
to be timid
i'm just telling you be a little bit
more respectful hear them out a little
bit right be willing to
support them just because they're you
know have their back during good and bad
times like you got to go through some of
that process together
but if it flips and it's just somebody
becoming too worried about losing people
you're no longer
leading that organization the
organization is leading you similar to
when kids are leading their parents
you know give a final thought on tom's
comment yeah um
great stat about the most dangerous
interaction is with cops is when they
pull you over
my question that is i would assume the
majority of interactions with cops
are when they pull you over i mean think
about how often are you interacting with
cops
unless you're at a freaking riot that
we're talking about here where you're
putting a camera in someone's face
on your day-to-day interactions you're
not dealing with cops like if you go to
like a sports game maybe they're outside
the arena
you know but like how often do you
interact with cops you interact with
cops
75 times a year apparently with all the
tickets that you get
but it's dangerous but it's also the
most likely situation to happen
interacting with cops and this goes back
to my initial point
you i mean i'm being very clear here you
if you get a 200
speeding ticket times 75 right whatever
bro i got 200
bucks for the common person out there
they get a 200 speeding ticket
plus they get points on their license
plus their insurance goes up their
[ __ ] day is ruined and now they don't
have the money to pay for the insurance
they're very small though it is a law it
is a law
no doubt i broke a law no doubt yeah but
you have the ability to pay for it no
questions
i also got tickets when i was broke to
your assuming i've been rich my entire
life
but you've been rich for good 20 years
now not 20 years 20 years ago i was 22
years old i was broke
no i started making 15 years 15 years
ago where are you going here
you shouldn't give a ticket to someone
who doesn't have the ability what i'm
saying that's not what i'm saying at all
i'm just saying a
number one most interactions are with
within someone getting pulled
over so not only is it the most
dangerous yeah
i assume the majority of interactions or
here's your ticket keep it moving
but if there's 10 million people getting
pulled over every year but also
obviously it's going to be very awesome
of interactions cops have with people
are those that broke the law
i broke a law yes everybody that they're
dealing they're getting a call to go to
someone's house because of domestic
violence they're getting the call to go
to someone's house because somebody
you know robbed them they're getting a
call to go because there was an accident
totally
everything is about so imagine your
entire life is you're calling to go to
deal with someone that broke the law
what a wonderful way to start your day
horrible
there you go but back to my initial
point yeah
there's a big difference in going to
someone's house because of a murder or
domestic violence
versus hey man you were going uh 50 and
a 35. it's like all right cool i'll take
the ticket
but like don't add insult to injury and
be like you don't need to be treated
like a criminal let me tell you
let me flip flip the conversation on you
about cops okay
my sister can totally remember a couple
of these two i'm not going to take a
couple because they're pretty bad
i can't stand bad cops and i call them
out
asap there's witnesses one time we're
going down to newport beach i was giving
a talk
uh at the balboa club and i was going my
expedition 22 years old this is at the
peak of my temper and i'm not
you know i only got 10 grand on a bank
saved up my money from working at
bally's and i'm using all that money to
grow my business which is not going well
now i'm driving down cop pulls me over
and he comes from the other side
okay and he comes with the gun yeah
pointed at the car i'm like what the
hell are you doing
so he comes to the side with his gun in
his hand
i said what the hell are you doing four
or five three we're right off the venice
exit you know where the venice exit is
right after four or five freeway yeah
exactly i said what are you doing
i was gonna ask you what you're doing
well there's been reports of a stolen
car said
so what the hell do you have a gun in
your hand so you see six people in this
car with a suit on
so how long you've been a cop none of
your business how long have you been a
cop
how long have you been a cop he wouldn't
answer that question for me
that's how i don't give in a cop so
finally what do i do i go show
up to court you know what he gave me a
ticket for no joke i'm actually not
joking here
going 71 on a freeway that was 65.
i got a ticket going 71 on 65. well you
broke the law pad but i broke the laws i
went to court
and i specifically wanted to know how
long that guy had been a cop you know
how long he had been a cop
90 days yeah he was a baby cop okay
walking up with a gun out the hell are
you doing walking up with a gun can you
imagine if you do that
yeah what are you doing you so there are
those cops
that use their badge and their gun as a
method of a weapon that are more
powerful than you
i cannot stand that at the highest level
but that's less than one percent i agree
okay less than one percent
for me to put that onus on the other 99
who are trying to do their best
i'm not going to do based on one person
you never use exception to say the
entire community is there because of one
percent
not going to happen
you